[Music]
what do you want to do for lunch today
god I could really go for like a greasy
hamburger or something you know but I
shouldn't you know what let's be bad
just this once
what if we got ice cream stop it
let's make bad Oh Jacob has texted me
about a drinking contest but I'm on
antibiotics let's be cuddly this guy
just invited it was sex party we should
go
I'm boyfriend we miss a bit screw it but
this is that card that come yelping
traffic to this should be kicking the
tail light tail eh yeah no way let's be
really bad I took this boot at all from
that car should we try to put a curse on
my upstairs neighbor who stomp strong
like an elephant let's be batter
according to this book on witchcraft
there's a potion in here that makes your
ex say only your name very sad but we
couldn't possibly be bad oh yes let's
summon a demon to get us out of our
necks still you're bored give to the
rich should we curse people so that they
only speak in YouTube comments
should we sacrifice this puppy to cars
Tiffany clad well who made fun of my
backpack in the ninth grade
no what are you even talking about
looking shooting adorable the flu I
don't know I don't know what's happening
to me you know that would be so so bad
sucking the life out of these children's
that we live forever yes my god were the
worst
[Applause]
[Music]